hi everyone I'm Jackie and I'm the head
of front-end development at Behance
which is an online platform for
showcasing and discovering creative work
today I want to tell you a little bit
about our journey growing and
maintaining a large code base in an era
where front-end technology is changing
extremely fast from our original days of
using vanilla CSS all the way through
the introduction of pre processors and
into our current day CSS nsj
implementations I'll go over some of our
trials and tribulations and growing
pains and I'll even air some of our
dirty laundry but perhaps most
importantly how I learned to stop
worrying and love the website the
front-end web development ecosystem is
moving insanely fast these days it seems
like a new tool or methodology for
authoring HTML CSS and JavaScript
becomes available every other day
whereas a few years ago there weren't
nearly as many tools with which to work
on these things probably in large part
because complex front-end requirements
like responsive web development or
single page web apps weren't even
concerns anywhere near our radars yet
but now we're seeing huge rapid
advancements in everything from the
languages themselves to how we generate
basically every single kind of code we
write to the frameworks we use to
organize our code all the way to the
build tools that we use to compile
optimize and serve our code and because
there's always some better or faster
tool becoming available it can feel
overwhelming to have to choose and adopt
these new technologies all the time this
is hard enough to do on a brand-new
project where there's no pre-existing
code concerns but it can be especially
hard in a large code base or one has
been around for a long time where when
the moment you add something new
suddenly everything else becomes legacy
code and now not only do you have all of
this new stuff that you need to learn
and maintain you also have to consider
how it's going to play with all of your
old code and how or even if you're ever
going to update that old code to
use this new stuff when you compound
these technical challenges with the
industry pressure that you should be
using a certain tool or doing things a
certain way in order to be a real web
developer it can create kind of a harsh
environment for being able to make the
best decisions for your team and for
your product and for your users which on
the code side that can lead to things
like an increase in technical debt or
missed project deadlines but on the
human side of things that can create
negative feelings like impostor syndrome
or burnout which are really harmful so
today I want to tell you about how we've
dealt with these kinds of challenges at
the hands over the years and if any of
you have ever felt like you've
experienced anything like these or might
ever experience anything like this I
want you to know you are not alone so
we've been evolving the ANSYS codebase
since 2010 when I joined the team eight
years ago they had just finished a
wholesale rewrite of the entire website
from scratch but since then we have not
started over we've just been working
within that same evolving codebase
through the years and we've moved
through a number of different template
engines CSS processors JavaScript
libraries and frameworks you name it I
joined as the fourth developer on the
team and since then we've grown to be
about 40 developers and in that time
we've faced a really wide variety of
challenges we are also constantly
considering which new technologies we
can use that'll serve us and the website
and the users needs best we've had to
figure out how to actually implement
these new technologies into our existing
stack even when there were massive
functional disparities with what was
already there we've had to figure out
when to start implementing these things
in particular we always have to balance
our product goals and roadmaps with our
developer happiness as well as the
health of the codebase and of course
we've had to clean up any messes we left
behind along the way so there's a ton of
opinions out there on the internet on
what the best or the right way to build
a website is
I'm not here to tell you that there is
any one right or wrong way to do any of
these things in fact I'm kind of here to
demonstrate the opposite what I do want
to tell you is about how we've handled
these challenges over the years how and
why we've made the decisions that we did
and how they did or did not work out for
us and what I really kind of want to
reveal is that no matter how pretty and
put together things may seem from the
outside whenever you pull back the
curtain there's no website or process
this ever really is perfect or pretty as
it may seem so first a little extra
insight in to be Hans's size and
complexity as of today I counted over 50
pages on our website which exist in
various states have logged in or out or
empty states or not and that's made up
of over 500 JavaScript files roughly the
same number of style sheets and almost a
thousand mark-up templates of course
this number has been in flux over the
years as we've removed various pages and
features and sections of the site but
the website has also evolved to become a
little bit more like a web app as
opposed to its traditional individual
paged website origins we now have way
more interactive modular components that
exist across many pages of the site for
example there's like a notifications and
a messages feed that you can see on any
page and other things like a project
pop-up or a user card that can be
incited from any many different areas of
the website as well but we have very
humble beginnings the screenshot is from
the wayback machine there used to be
something on the right side but some
things get lost even to the Internet so
back in 2010 when I first joined we
weren't using anything except for Van is
s2 style the website I would say that
our CSS development style back then
could be called copy/paste driven
development at this point because we
pretty much had no tools on the front
end to help us reduce repetition we're
really using any methodologies or naming
conventions to help keep our CSS clean
so this is what the website looked like
and I would say that anything on the
website that wasn't plain text or a
solid color was probably an image CSS
just wasn't nearly as robust as it is
today and we were trying to create
something a little more visually
interesting than native CSS would allow
at the time but we started to get
comfortable using CSS features for
visual flair where we could
understanding that the website didn't
have to look exactly the same in every
single browser all the time and honestly
I think once our designers realized that
we could make any CSS gradient that we
wanted without them having to make
images for it I got to become very
intimately familiar with this tool there
was like a dozen different ways to make
gradients and different browsers and I
definitely was not about to memorize all
that syntax so in time browser
technologies starting to pick up more
steam CSS as a language was advancing
and we were really having a lot of fun
with all the cool little visual tricks
and treats that we could do with CSS and
we were starting to get comfortable
moving away from creating images for
things that we were now excited to be
able to implement with just native CSS
we had an interesting additional
challenge and that we also had all of
these offshoots at the Hantz that were
themed galleries for different creative
fields and these white label almost
miniature B Hans's for schools and
organizations which all use the same
markup and styles in JavaScript as the
main behance website but with an
additional stylesheet loaded to actually
customize them each for their own look
or brand now all of these lived within
the same one code base which of course
meant that if you change something on
the main behance website you had to go
and make sure that you didn't break it
on any of these other 40-plus versions
of the website no big deal so by now we
had a clear need for a tool that was
going to help us with our CSS
development not only we're vendor
prefixes starting to slip through the
cracks but thanks to all of these themed
galleries and websites we were
absolutely inundated with copy and
pasted CSS we're largely the differences
were things like font names or color
values
fortunately by this time CSS
preprocessors are really starting to
pick up steam and they were looking like
the perfect tools to help us with our
CSS in the shape and make things a bit
more dry now the story I'm about to tell
is not about the merits of any one CSS
preprocessor over the other but I do
want to use it as a real-world example
of the messy path to choosing
implementing and using new tools so for
us we were debating between less and
sass both excellent tools on their own
but we wanted to proper due diligence
and make sure that we picked the right
tool for our specific needs ultimately
sass had a more compelling
implementations and features for our use
case and compass on top of that offered
us a ton of extra power that was going
to be absolutely perfect for theming all
of those sites and for our sprite
management I mean sass and compass were
seriously set to improve our lives
drastically the answer for us could not
have been more clear we obviously went
with less why would we do that in our
case we ended up going with less for a
couple of reasons at the time there was
only Ruby sass and since Behance was not
built on a Ruby stack it wasn't easy for
us easy for us to implement or even
start using sass and it was a little bit
intimidating since less could easily be
compiled by just downloading a
convenient little GUI app to your
computer it actually is a really low
barrier to entry for us we were still a
very tiny dev team at this point but
this meant that we could start getting a
lot of the benefits of a CSS
preprocessor much sooner and with way
less friction and engineering time than
if we had chosen to go with sass at that
point it afforded us another interesting
benefit as well in that we were actually
able to use less as a proof of concept
that implementing a CSS preprocessor was
a worthwhile investment the time it took
to get it up and running for everyone to
use paid off drastically in development
time and development improvements down
the line which meant that we were able
to get more to
by in for actually adopting SAS as well
as negotiate for the development time
that we needed to do so and make the
switch to the tool that we ultimately
felt would serve us best but our journey
does not end there
although we had decided that the higher
investment in setting up SAS was worth
it we did have to cut some corners to
get there to complicate things we were
now dealing with the dreaded technical
debt of working in a code base that had
partially vanilla CSS and partially less
syntax and now we would have to spend
the time to convert that all into SAS
and we still didn't have a tech stack
that could compile SAS for us but what
we could do was install Ruby and SAS on
each of our individual computers
and compile and commit the SAS and CSS
to our repositories from there now we
violated a lot of web development best
practices by compiling CSS on our own
machines instead of by using a build
tool within the tech stack and we were
committing an even worse crime of
actually committing compiled code to our
repository I seriously doubt you to ever
find a medium think piece advocating for
this kind of implementation and it gives
me some anxiety to admit on stage in
front of you all that we were committing
such an egregious violation of best
practices by having literally hundreds
of compiled CSS files in our repository
but on the flip side I also cannot
overstate how much benefit we were
getting by having SAS available to us in
this way for what sounds like a
nightmare situation on the surface I
have to say for the most part actually
worked really well for us suddenly we
were able to build our themed galleries
and white labeled websites in a fraction
of the time which meant that we were
helping our users in our mission to give
more exposure to creatives we were able
to do it with way less code than before
which meant that now our code base
became much easier to understand and
maintain
although committing compiled code is
considered a bad practice for a large
complex code base with a lot of
interdependencies it actually ended up
giving us extremely clear visibility
into the reach that any single change
actually was having and the last cool
thing is that we suddenly had tools that
could do some grunt work for us
for example this meant that our
designers could focus on working on and
designing things that actually mattered
rather than spending their time doing
menial tasks like stitching sprites
together so in this case we were able to
find a balance between a subpar
technical implementation and
overwhelming developer and designer
happiness as well as code health by
reducing a lot of the technical debt in
our CSS but what happens when you need a
tool that doesn't really seem to exist
yet around this time we started working
on a new product it was a single page
web app for task management we called
action method online being that it was a
completely brand new product and totally
different from behance
we were starting from scratch and we had
an excellent and rare opportunity to try
out new technologies and we got to do
this without having to worry about
retrofitting it into any existing code
now I think we chose less for this one
because of the timing but on the
JavaScript side we ended up making the
decision to write our own JavaScript MVC
framework which we called NBD is and we
built it at a time when actually angular
and backbone were extremely popular
well-established frameworks so why would
we bother writing our own well if you
look at this timeline we were actually
doing this at a time when there weren't
a ton of alternative options or the ones
that were out were kind of new adopting
a young technology in a product that you
anticipate and hope is going to live for
years it's kind of a non zero risk move
now I'm not saying that writing your own
framework or using an existing one is
better
worse than the other but for the size of
our team and the needs of our product at
the time being able to iterate on our
own front-end framework was just
precisely what we needed at the time and
what ended up happening is that action
method online became a really good
proving ground for our JavaScript
framework because it was born and forged
for specific interactive and data-driven
purposes we were actually able to apply
the techniques and practices that we
learned in action method online back on
behance we were able to start using some
of the more complex features of this
framework for uploading and editing
features that we were starting to add to
behance as well so by this time Behance
was evolving from its static website
roots to become more responsive and a
bit more modular but executing this kind
of huge paradigm shift was a tremendous
undertaking for us there was literally
nothing about how the site was built to
that point that was conducive to being
responsive the way we built the site
layout was completely rigid the existing
design was not immediately adaptable to
smaller screen sizes and we were still
lacking the tools on the front end that
we needed to clearly structure and
implement the kind of responsive
functionality and modularity that we
really wanted to so we knew we wanted to
make the website responsive but despite
the challenges in place by the existing
foundation we knew a full rewrite of the
website was simply out of the question
it was a huge website and it would have
taken far too long so we continued
working on Behance we would add new
features and convert the site over to be
responsive page by page and we used our
JavaScript framework NBD for any new
code that we were creating and then we
would update any existing areas of the
site to use it as needed also whether it
was because that page was due for
maintenance or any other kind of update
so both sass and NBD carried us all the
way into 2015 when we
started work on another brand new single
page web app this time it was a website
builder called Adobe portfolio and it
stood to be the most complex single page
web app that we've created to date we
had a ton of new technical challenges of
portfolio that we had never had to deal
with before even in our previous single
page web app what we wanted was build a
full GUI what you see is what you get
editor where by using one of any
literally hundreds of customization
dialogs you can make change to your
website and see it reflected in the
editor in real time we needed to do this
all while maintaining an editor chrome
that needed to not interfere or
intersect with user customizations in
any way so we started building portfolio
with NBD but building and maintaining
framework is not without its risks and
downsides either and by now we've been
starting to feel some of the growing
pains of actually using our own
homegrown framework I was originally
built by just one of our developers and
maintained by only a couple more so this
meant that it didn't move particularly
fast meant that other open source
frameworks were moving at a much faster
rate it also meant that it was much more
challenging for new hires to learn it
documentation on it was sparse because
the developers who knew how it worked
were busy developing whether it was the
framework or for new features for our
websites and then also the universe of
resources to get help with it was scoped
entirely to an extremely small portion
of our dev team which then unfortunately
made it hard for anyone who needed help
to be self-sufficient on the flip side
popular open source frameworks came with
the benefit of way more active invisible
communities to tap into for help which
not only means you have a way bigger
pool of resources to get help from but
it also means that there is a community
need that you can give back to when you
solve a specific challenge or
interesting problem yourself so by then
it was easy enough to acknowledge that
our homegoing framework was no longer
really the best tool for our team or
new types of products and features that
we were building after spending some
time on portfolios development we turned
our attention back to Behance and in the
time that we had been building adobe
portfolio our designers had been working
on designing a whole new look and feel
for the entire Behance website and we
wanted this to make a big splash we
wanted it to be a release where the look
and feel of the entire up site would
change for our users all at once and
despite this once again we still knew
that starting the whole thing over from
scratch was simply not an option for us
we'd adopted modular JavaScript with
requirejs and attempted to scope and
componentize our CSS as much as possible
using FEM but the truly Scopes nature of
CSS and j/s was becoming impossibly
enticing for our increasingly modular
web sites and web apps so with a big
overhaul on our plates the time was once
again ripe for us to look for new
technology now in the same way that the
industry at large has a lot of opinions
on the best tools to use so does any
individual given dev team so what we did
to figure out what was gonna work best
for us is we would hold group
discussions lunch and learns different
knowledge sharing sessions for anyone
who is interested where we would discuss
the pros and cons and the merits of
different jobs for frameworks or CSS and
J's solutions and then when we could get
some kind of agreement on which one's
seen the most compelling we would
actually try them out by building parts
of the website for them specifically our
at the admin section of our websites
which were just pages that only
employees can access for different
maintenance tasks but what it meant was
that we could actually start using these
things in a near real-world proving
ground
so for Behance we ultimately decided on
view and CSS modules as our preferred
tools and once again we continue to use
a lot of the same techniques that we for
implementing new technology that we had
done in the past who we exclusively
built new features using these new
and frameworks which meant that they got
to be in use immediately we rebuilt
existing UI components such as buttons
and inputs using these new tools and
frameworks alongside their existing
implementations which could then be
moved over to different areas of the
site as those pages were updated to use
view as well and perhaps most critically
we did all of this development behind
what we call feature flags what this is
is just a check in the code that serves
one set of code or another depending on
your users gatekeeper setting which
means that we could build everything
that we needed alongside the existing
website without worrying about
interfering with it while also still
having the ability to see all of this
new stuff in action in a production
environment even before it was ready for
its public debut and so this actually
brings us to where we are today the
website is not fully converted to view
and CSS and j/s but we continue to
follow the same practices as we update
and develop new features and actually as
an aside although we are fairly recently
into our transition into view we've
actually recently made the decision to
switch to react which I don't have time
to go into now but would be happy to
chat with anyone about after this if you
want so if you look at the arc of CSS
development over the last eight years it
has changed drastically in 2010 our
biggest concerns were around perfecting
the slickest CSS gradient and getting
the website to look pixel perfect to the
mock-ups that the designers gave us but
by 2018 not only are we concerned with
how the website looks but we also have
to think about how to optimize our code
for the least repetition for the best
browser performance for how it functions
in the most browsers and devices and I
think we've ever had to deal with since
the CSS has become more closely
intertwined to our JavaScript and markup
in modern frameworks than ever before
our concerns are no longer isolated to
the CSS itself
and because JavaScript technology and
frameworks move so fast too we end up
having a much bigger and more robust
ecosystem that we need to have a deep
understanding of for an end development
is hard for a nun Engineering is hard
but I encourage empathy in your
decision-making and interactions around
it every technical choice is relative
and there is no right or wrong way to
build a website so in case the examples
so far didn't illustrate the beautiful
unique messy paths that web development
can take I'm gonna air a little bit of
bee Hans's dirty laundry in case any of
you have ever felt bad about the
skeletons in your codebases closet maybe
this will help you feel like you are not
alone hopefully this is also therapeutic
for me so the first one is that we're
actually still using three different
templating engines on cross the website
which is absolutely a relic of the
transitions that we've made over time
and depending on what page you're
viewing you might actually be seeing all
three of them in action all at once this
just so happens to be the very first
page you see when you log into our
website I searched our code base for
some - dues because I figured there
could be some fun stuff in there and I
immediately came across this one in the
head tag of part of our website it says
to do there is a lot of stuff included
here that is just unnecessary cool that
sounds bad and also isn't particularly
actionable but I had never noticed this
before so I checked the git blame
because I was curious to see how long
this had been a problem for okay so
while I was looking through the to do so
I thought okay I might as well actually
like clean up some of them while I'm in
here so I found this one and it says to
do remove after Statistics are fixed so
ok I found this in the CSS for our
notifications and honestly I could not
figure out what status statistics has or
ever had to do with our notifications so
I checked the blame on this one also
still no idea so here's a little bit of
a longer one
this one says to do this is due to
chrome 43 point zero point two three
five seven point six five introducing a
phantom sub pixel width enlargement on
parent containers remove when fixed so
okay that's a nice descriptive to do
although it's not immediately clear why
a width property is a bad thing here
that seems fine to me but whatever this
is hopeful information so let's see if
chrome has updated at all since this was
written I went to pick Wikipedia to
check when this specific version of
chrome was released over three years ago
but okay let's see what version chrome
is even up to cool I left that one alone
also we have a page on our website that
we never made responsive it's not even
like it doesn't get traffic people visit
this page granted it's not the most
popular part of the website but we just
quite simply never prioritized it
and finally my personal favorite if you
recall I said how we started committing
compiled CSS to the repo way back in
2011
yeah well we did that for over five
years and we only stopped doing it about
a year and a half ago very long after a
lot of viable solutions had already
become available talk about embarrassing
so if it sounds like I'm saying our
website is kind of messy and imperfect
good that is what I'm saying
but ultimately I'm actually proud to say
that I work on Behance
even now that you all know how the
sausage is made
it's not perfect but the difference
between not perfect and bad is all in
how much you focus on it the closer you
examine something the worse it seems but
everything that we've built is the
result of hard work and smart ideas and
great teamwork
I consider myself extremely lucky to
work with a driven and compassionate
group of people who care deeply about
the work that they create the products
that they're building and the impact
that it has on the lives of the people
who use it and ultimately these are the
things that I think really make our
industry what it is and these are the
values that are way more important than
any of the latest frameworks or tools or
technologies or any pristine or perfect
codebase thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]